هنا في استوديو الجزيره لتغطيه الانتخابات
ينضم الينا ايضا مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد
العظيم محمد عبد العظيم لافت انه لا مظاهر
انتخابيه في خلفيه المراسلين وهذا لانه
مرحله الصمت الانتخابي وانا لاحظت فعلا
يعني في طريقي الى الى المكتب لاحظت ان كل
الصور وكل الشعارات رفعت تماما وهذا
التزام تام بما يعرف بالصمت الانتخابي هذا
يفرض
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات في تركيا يفرض
على جميع الناخبين والمرشحين
والاحزاب رفع شعاراتها والتوقف عن دعايه
الانتخابيه حتى الحديث الى وسائل الاعلام
وبعض السياسيين المرشحين خصوصا اردوغان
اوغلو لم يستطيعوا ان يتحدثوا قاموا
بجولات بدون حديث مثلا
اردوغان ذهب الى جامع صوفيا وذهب لصلاه
المغرب واجتمع عدد الاف من الحشود
ذهب لزياره قبر
اتاتورك في اشارات رمزيه من كلا الطرفين
لخلفيتهم ولي اهدافهم ولمشاريعهم التي
يقدموها للجمهور التركي وهي هذه اخر
الرسائل التي حاولت المرشحان توصيلها
للجمهور التركي في بعد عمليه الصمت
الانتخاب استطلاعات راي كثيره شاهدناها
منذ حوالي ربما شهر
وبعضها متضارب بعضها متقارب اخر هذه
الاستطلاعات الى ماذا وصلت طبعا جلال
تعرفه نحن منذ اسبوع سويتا ونواكب كل هذه
الاستطلاعات الراي استطلاعات الراي لا
يمكن الركون الى استطلاعات الراي في تركيا
باعتبار ان كل مراكز التي تقوم بها
الاستطلاعات هي تابعه للاحزاب بشكل مباشر
او غير مباشر
خلال الايام الماضيه الاستطلاعات المراكز
القريبه من حزب العداله والتنميه تظهر
اردوغان على منافسه بثلاثه واربعه نقاط
واعلى استطلاع عربي اعطاه خلال اسبوع
الماضي هو خمسين فاصل نصف او اربعه
المئه
واستطلاعات الراي القريبه من حزب العداله
والتنميه
من تحالف الشعب ايضا كانت تعطي
كجدار التقدم في كل استطلاعات الراي واعلى
نسبه اعطته هي 51 ونصف في استطلاعه الراي
وهذا يؤشر على تقارب المرشحين في هذه
المنافسه وان الخيارات مفتوحه والتقارب
مفتوح اريد ان نشير فقط الى ان اخر
استطلاعات الراي الغير معلنه استطلاعات
معلنه تقدم الجمهور وهناك استطلاعات راي
غير معلنه تقوم بها الاحزاب صحيح اخر
استطلاع رايي قدم قبل
بضع ساعات اي بعد الصمت الانتخابي الى
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان قام به والتنميه
اعطاه ما نسبته 48 ونصف الى 49 هذه اعلى
نسبه سيحصل عليها الرئيس وقالوا ان
استطلاعاتهم التي شملت 20 مدينه سته الاف
مواطن
جدار اخرى واخذ
45% والترجيحات تقول انهم سيذهبون الى
جوله ثانيه في الانتخابات وان اصوات محرمه
ان جاء ستذهب معظمها الى الذين انسحب من
الانتخابات ستذهب الى
وقسم منها سيذهب الى سنان اوغن الذي تقدم
منذ امس واليوم الى خمسه فاصله سبعه
بالعشره اي انه اصوات محرم انجا في معظمها
ذهبت الى سنان اوغان وهو من سيدفع يبدو
انه هو من سيدفع الطرفين للذهاب الى جوله
ثانيه في الاقتراح نوضح للمشاهدين لماذا
جوله ثانيه لان كل مرشح يحتاج الى من 50%
لكي يفوز ويحسن من الجوله الاولى البرامج
الانتخابيه سواء كانت الرئاسيه او
التشريعيه كانت مختلفه عبد العظيم يعني
بالتاكيد هناك برامج مختلفه
يركز على الجانب الاقتصادي وعلى العوده
بتركيا لهويتها القديمه والتوجه نحو الغرب
بينما
اردوغان
يتحدث عن ايضا برامج اقتصاديه
ومشروع
بداه سيكمله في خلال السنوات الخمس
القادمه وانه يؤكد على دور تركيا المحوري
في المنطقه والمحيط الاقليمي والمحيط
الدولي لكن جلال وانت ايضا ممكن لاحظت
خلال الايام الماضيه المرشحون
المتنافسون
بعيدا عن كل هذه البرامج الانتخابيه هناك
حاله استقطاب صحيح في الشارع التركي لا
علاقه لها بالبرامج الانتخابيه هناك من
سيذهب لصناديق الاقتراع بغض النظر عن كيف
سيكون البرنامج الانتخابات ربما ستكون
اعلى نسبه مشاركه تصل الى 90% وهي نسب
خياليه في تركيا وربما التحالفات غير
المتجانسه تفرض ما تفضلت به شكرا لك عبد
العظيم محمد مكتب الجزيره في